and i don't know i think there's
something about like biblical
institutions
that have been running men out of them
the last like 50 years what do you mean
like like why are all these men they're
men used to be really involved in the
church yes and but they're not anymore
so something about these institutions
are running men out
talk to me come on
no they can't hear you come in you can
take me i have to pee take my mic
if you want see what i'm saying okay i'm
gonna repeat
there's someone on our couch that didn't
want to be in it
in europe yes okay one is because men
might be seen as i don't think i can say
this one youtube
played on youtube it flags it
okay yeah involved with the young
children
yeah
yeah and then the second is the rise of
independent women
in the church it's a great segue to
feminism
what i've honestly what i'm thinking
about when we talk about church
institutions is like
one thing person this is just a side
note i think a lot of people
need to
focus more
on their relationship with god yes than
a church because i had
growing up i had a mother who put all
her time in the church this and that
this and that and then there will be
like shady things happening in the
church is going on
so why but at the end of the day
basically it's all about your
relationship with god yes
so all the other stuff don't really
matter
so when we put all our time
and uh doing this and that for the
pastor for i don't think i think it's a
waste of time not a waste of time but
like you can put your efforts in better
things
well every institution is going to get
corrupted at some point it's like
there's no there's not a perfect
institution
but but i think but i think that you got
to ask yourself the question does that
mean we just do away with them and don't
use them at all no no no i'm not yeah
i'm not saying that but know
know where your focus should be
know what your time should go into yes
basically in my in my opinion like
there's certain things that the church
do
that you should
feed into prayer helping out each other
i remember i was at prep school
in north carolina i was good i was in i
don't even need the prep school but i
was at a prep school and every week
the pastor the pastor's out here getting
um he said oh yeah
offerings for this offering so that he's
like yeah the prep school here
uh everyone would do an offer for the
floor we never saw the floor got done up
nothing oh my god and i was putting i
was putting in 20 us dollars i didn't
have no money at the time but the floors
were bad and
the the pastor gave me a a sermon and it
hit me i was like i said move me i'm
like yeah i'm up i'm gonna tap my car
for this 20. it moved me and then after
everyone's like yo what are you doing
don't do it i'm like why bro this guy
does this every year he's never fixed
the floor jeez and he has like
six cars in his garage um so those type
of things when i say right when i say
focus on your relationship with god and
not yeah and not believe in yeah
yeah that's that's yeah those are the
points that i mean you know yeah not to
interrupt you but that man ultimately
has an answer to god for that
he has to answer to god for manipulating
god's people or the sheep
or or the the or the bride of the church
for his own personal benefit he has to
answer god for that and that and and
this and that's what i agree with you
you got i was saying the same i write a
lot i love to write that's one of my uh
greatest gifts
creativity is my number one number two
of the right
and
one of the things that i write um
sometimes daily is that you have that
form your own personal relationship with
god because pastors and certain people
can manipulate who you are
and what they want
so um outside of
religion what else are your deal
breakers like so you have to have the
same religion as a girl
more times than not
abraham abrahamic faith okay but
more times like i will probably lean
towards uh christian and you're his
friend so does he does he only date does
he only date the christian girls i don't
know what he dates i just met chav i'm
glad i'm fortunate to meet this oh you
just met him i thought you guys knew
each other i noticed in august is a
great guy stand up guy
mind me i can't speak on him but me
personally
my deal breakers
will be people
that really don't have no driving
motivation like i said i was raised by a
single mother so i get out of the mud
so i don't want anybody that's lazy i
want no one that doesn't have no
ambition like i don't care
where you are in your life at this stage
when you're speaking when you're when
we're speaking
you have to tell like if we're talking
and say what do you want to do in the
future
you have to tell me oh my plans to do
this and that are you have an idea if
you're just sitting around okay so what
else what else what else
what else
but hey i'm all about connections we are
heterosexual men who are attracted to
creatures
would you guys date a girl that's
overweight
no i have a six-pack
jesus christ god please forgive me
i want somebody that has a quote-unquote
active lifestyle
and
i probably attract people in that
section so know this but i don't think
overweight people single mom
single mom better response a better
response
hey
a better response would have been
that's just not my preference
i'm sorry i have to recuperate because
you did you date a girl as a kid though
yeah this means honestly
my my oldest brother my oldest brother
he is dating a woman well it's her
fiance now they can get married in uh
july
and
when i came to london for the first time
i was born in england i came back to
london for the first time he's dating a
lady and she had a child already but the
way they had the relationship
her child and then my my brother it was
just so like seamless you know like it's
just as natural having a child doesn't
really affect me in general like if i
really love you i love your child at the
same time yes so that's not really a
deal breaker in my opinion
if you have someone that's toxic in a
relationship then it might be a factor
where it goes let's say your your ex
partner with them you don't have a good
relationship with it it might be a
little techy it might be
it might ruin our hinder things
especially
you having a child in general mm-hmm it
doesn't really affect how i feel about
you and if i
if i love you and i feel like i can take
you seriously then obviously i'll be in
the workforce i wouldn't i wouldn't you
wouldn't no no children are beautiful i
love kids i just
i think
like i'm out of you so you don't rate it
no i mean look at i love i really do
like i love kids like i get really
excited when i see babies because
they're like all chubby and stuff you
know
but um i don't know i just feel like
there's something special about like
having your first child like with
somebody that's someone that already
yeah yeah like together and i just don't
like it's like a bond you're supposed to
have with like one person i think